thanks for everyone for being here today
I'm gonna be talking about how Red Hat
is experimenting with different deep
learning architectures to address
various business problems originally I
was willing to be talking about
recurrent healing networks but I decided
to add in a couple of other deep
learning models that we've been playing
with because I thought it might be of
interest to this crowd and so a quick
rundown what we're going to do imma
start off with a brief background of
deep learning just to get everyone on
the same page from there I'm going to a
model that tries to predict customers
who are going to drop their
subscriptions so red has a subscription
model and so that's something that we're
obviously interested in doing the second
model is going to be a model for
predicting whether or not a customer
will escalate a support case and both of
those those first two models I mentioned
our recurrent neural networks the next
model is it worked a Veck model that one
of my colleagues who's that pi data this
week Diego Fernandez worked on and then
the last model is my implementation of a
paper from Microsoft Research which is
basically a deep learning take on
semantic semantic search and so I tried
to make my slides really I try to design
them so that they encourage exploration
and so you can find my slides right now
on my website so if you google my name
in quotes that should be the first link
and then you can find this find the
slides there and I've links basically
scattered throughout the slides
encourage you to click on them including
most of the the images are linked to
their sources so you have more
information and so what is deep learning
it's a model that is loosely inspired by
the brain that learns complex
associations between variables it is not
magic despite what media might have you
believe these days it is just math and
so what is actually happening this is
basically your typical feed-forward
neill network and if you guys are at the
graph talking yesterday you know at
these circles are nodes and that the
arrows are edges and basically what
you're trying to do is each of these
groups of edges represents matrix in
your model and so all
deep learning is is basically a series
of linear algebra operations that then
get passed through some sort of
nonlinear function typically and then
they try to make a prediction and so
what you're trying to do with deep
learning is learn the parameters of
these matrices that minima are minimizer
here right and so the way that works can
practice is that you randomly guess your
initial weights for these parameters you
calculate the amount of error you have
and then using calculus and partial
derivatives you perturb these weights a
little bit constantly until you get to
an error that's acceptable and so I
think a lot of data science today you
can do without really understanding
deeply the math behind the models deep
learning is not at that state yet so
sort of step zero if you want to get
into deep learning as to get Strang's
linear algebra and it's applications go
through that get a really good
understanding of linear algebra and then
you'll basically be ready to get into
the software part and so on the previous
slide I mentioned how later layers tend
to learn more and more abstract concepts
in the model and a sort of hard to
conceptualize I think and so I like to
put in this slide to give you basically
a visual indication of what that means
and so this these results are from a
paper a few years ago that really put
convolutional neural networks on the map
and convolutional neural networks are
basically this specialized form of a
neural network that's really good for
computer vision in this particular test
what the goal is is to its object
recognition in images right and so a few
years ago this competition was held this
particular research group gives you
convolutional neural network they
achieved unprecedented results which was
awesome right but the really cool thing
is that when they looked at what the
lower layers were learning in this model
they were learning these really
interesting filters right so learning
things like edges oriented in different
directions color gradients and other
types of patterns and so you can imagine
how if the early layer isn't learning
these simple features how later layers
might combine you know things like edges
circles or something like
and then a later layer might say okay
these types of circles are wheels
these ones are eyes and that the final
stage you can then make a prediction car
face etc okay so feed for and you'll you
know neural networks are really awesome
they're really powerful but they have
one significant limitation which is that
they require fixed size input and so
recurrent neural networks are basically
a solution to that problem and the way
recurrent neural networks work is they
basically and so why would we want you
know variable length data so time series
right and so if you're in a subscription
model like Red Hat some of our customers
have been with us for months some of
them have been with us for years so how
can we incorporate all of that data into
a single model it's a recurrent neural
networks are the answer in a lot of
cases and so the way they work is they
basically stack up or put feed-forward
neural networks side-by-side and then
they connect the hidden layers from the
different time steps right and so if you
remember from the first slide what we're
trying to learn is those those three
matrices right of those layers of
connections we basically just add
another matrix here and so the recurrent
neural network you're trying to learn in
this particular case the matrix that
it's dotted with your input the one that
gets dotted with your hidden layer to
the output and then a third matrix that
gets dotted between the hidden layers
okay and so each of those matrices are
used for each time step which is what a
lot of these models to be trained okay
and just a quick aside on recurrent
neural networks how cool they are Google
put out this paper a couple years ago
where they were built a they used
recurrent neural network to translate
English to other languages and so
basically what that looks like is they
feed in words from an English sentence
and then they output the predictions are
the words from the language that they're
trying to translate it to you and so
they achieved really great results but
the really cool thing again was that
when they fed in an English sentence and
then took the last hidden layer and
took the first two pieces the first two
pcs of aprons looked opponent analysis
and plotted those sentences what they
found is that semantically similar
senses Matt to up close to each other in
this space which is really like
fantastic right so the point there is
that these models can be really powerful
okay so that's a very brief introduction
to the theory the tools that are
available are summarized basically on
this slide and so the major back ends
basically that people use these days are
Theano and tensor flow and they
basically do the same type of thing
they are mathematical expression
libraries where you basically define how
your data will flow through your model
and then you can train it from there and
so I mentioned linear algebra is a good
thing to learn also like sort of step
two is functional programming and so if
you're not used to functional
programming so this comes up in like
function programs like things like Scala
as well or spark as spirit has a lot of
functional aspects to it basically it's
different in that you're not when you
like define like a particular operation
so we take a dot product of your
variables it's not being calculated
right there it's not being executed
you're just like defining the graph of
how the computation is being performed
and so that's basically what this this
image is trying to represent so Theon in
tensile tensor fold are basically very
similar things doing very similar
computational graph type things and so
also I want to emphasize that both of
these libraries are broader than deep
learning for example Theano I met a
woman here from Duke chin who their lab
is using in Theano
to do variational inference and then if
you're familiar with PI MC it's this
Python library for doing Bayesian
inference they also use Theano as your
back-end so it's this really powerful
library for designing models basically
and so the last thing I want to mention
is these two rappers lasagna and Karis
they are pure deep learning stuff so
they basically build on lasagna and
carrots you see on Oh Karis can use
either Theano or tensorflow as the
backend but they like basically
implement calm
deep learning models to make it a little
bit easier to use okay so getting to the
model actually an insert my timer I bet
so yeah I'll definitely need that cue
yeah so the first model the motivation
here is that Red Hat offers a lot of
products right most of the customers are
able to take advantage of those products
some of the customers have trouble
getting most out of their subscriptions
though right and so we basically wanted
to help those folks out and so the
hypothesis that were me working with
when we were building our model is that
a customer's decision to keep drop or
add the Red Hat assets is at least
partially influenced by their experience
with Red Hat and so external factors
though like market trends also probably
play a role we're not going to be
incorporating those in this particular
model but in the future that's obviously
something that's more information that
we would like to include and so this is
just a quick no graphical representation
right has these products a lot of these
companies are like using them really
cool ways but some of these some of the
customers might be a little overwhelmed
with the offerings so how can we find
those people and reach out to them okay
and so the basic model building type or
data and model pipeline is outline right
here it's very typical for data
scientists you collect the data from
your different sources form some
intermediate machine learning and data
science steps on those data sources and
then in this case because we're working
with their current network I'm gonna put
that data in time series format and in
this particular case we are looking at
18 months of historical data and we're
trying to forecast six months in the
future how many of their assets that
they're going to be dropping and so just
a few general recommendations when
you're doing data size at least have
come in handy for of me is to be
granular and so if you have a particular
component of data that has sub
components use those sub components
that's just more information for your
models to learn from also use bins and
segregations and so for example Red Hat
has cases right support cases customers
make comments and so your your first
instinct might be to say okay let's see
how many comments this customer made
this month so if a customer made a
hundred comments though in a month they
could have made
and comments on a single case or they
could have made ten comments on ten
different cases right and that gives you
very different information I think so
try to be grand you are trying to use
bins so the number time a customer made
five comments number times customer made
ten comments etc etc and then finally
take advantage of unstructured data
this part doesn't need be really
advocated here but if Red Hat sits on a
bunch of text that's a ton of
information about our customers right
and so try to incorporate that into your
models if possible yeah and so I am a
software engineer a senior software
engineer actually a recent promotion on
the customer experience and engagement
team and that means we have basically
access to these three different data
sources the customer portal which is
where we basically log all of the web
activity that our customers are all
their activity on the website we also
have the cases data that I mentioned
before so customer has an issue with
their software they open a case it
creates this dialogue between Red Hat
and the customer a lot of information
there and then finally we have the
assets and entitlements data which are
their actual subscriptions and so we
know like what type of product it is how
long we've had the product what quantity
they have that whether or not they've
had had evaluations or betas before they
got the before they bought the product
the full product etc okay and so I'm
just going to sort of walk through the
basic data pipeline right now the first
step is to collect the portal data and
this slides actually out-of-date so that
we we saw this data we used store it all
we still do actually store on a new
cluster and so the way I process it
before was using a pig script to do some
MapReduce stuff but we actually migrate
a lot of this into a redshift database
now and so a lot of this is actually
out-of-date but the regardless the point
here is you're trying to count the
number of times that these customers are
looking at different page types the
second one is probably more interesting
in my opinion and basically what we're
trying to do here is we're finally
capture sort of the behavior of the
customer on the website for the month
and so you can imagine how the web pages
that a customer looks at during a
certain time period are probably
correlated together right there probably
like giving you information about the
particular problem or the type of
technology that the customer is
interested in at that time and so with
that in mind what we tried to do here is
basically represent we built this big
matrix where each row is a specific
account at a specific month in time and
each column is a different URL that they
could have visited on the customer
portal website and we basically the
values in those columns are the
proportion of time or the proportion of
page views that the customer visit that
particular URL for that month and so
what we did what we then did because we
want to sort of learn this like latent
explanation of that type of behavior is
did a single value decomposition on that
matrix and so if you're familiar with
like matrix decomposition that's
basically exactly what we did here this
matrix is very big and very sparse and
so if you guys haven't dealt with that a
good solution is to use a compressed
matrix form and in this particular case
we use a compressed sparse row matrix
and so it basically changes the way the
data is stored on the back end to make
it a lot smaller you basically ignore
the zeros of the way it's stored and so
the second or the third step I guess is
to collect the cases in assets data from
the databases and this is just a bunch
of my sequel queries and then we map all
of that data to the account ID year and
month which makes accessing it easier
when we're trying to write all this
different disparate data states
different data sources out to a single
time series format for step four this is
another idea I mentioned Diego Fernandez
earlier this was his idea originally and
so the idea is that we have millions
support cases over a million support
cases but on
a very small fraction of them do we have
customer feedback on how they felt about
the case and so Diego's idea was like
maybe we could build a model that
predicts the customer response and use
that to make predictions on all of the
cases that we don't have that response
for and use that data then in our mollis
like sort of it's not quite same as
supervised because we're not going back
and correcting it but that's
approximately what it is and so yeah and
so basically we did exactly that we used
a gradient boosted machine using the
extra D boost and so if you're familiar
with Kaggle that's sort of like the
bee's knees over there and what we found
is that we can basically we can't we
can't predict the exact score but we can
basically distinguish between positive
and negative experiences and so that's
what we did we went back for every case
that we don't have a support score or
yeah support score for we assign it that
and then we incorporate that data into
the model and so again being granular
and talking about bins we count the
number of times that they have like a
want or a negative versus a positive
instead of just like averaging the
predictive score that the model gave us
and yeah like I wanna I mean I don't
think it emphasizes this point again
neural networks are definitely not magic
right because everyone on Kaggle or for
a lot of competitions on Kaggle people
are using XG boost and they're winning
right there are other competitions where
neural networks are working better but
it's really there's definitely an
interesting dynamics there about the
different properties basically of how
these models are trained for the next
step this is also pretty interesting so
we wanted to customers are open these
support cases right and we want to
basically capture what they're talking
about in their support cases and so this
work was done by Michael Coleman who was
an intern with Red Hat and what he did
was performed a late endear sleigh alik
or built a late and eerily allocation
model on the case documents and what a
lady really allocation model does it
basically models your document as a bag
of words and it says the distribution
these words is basically based on the
mixture of topics that define that
particular document and so once you
build this model you can then assign a
vector of topic distributions to new
documents and so that's basically what
we did we built this model and then we
went back over all of the cases and got
their topic vector and then we basically
sum those up for a month and that gives
you approximately account of how many
times they were talking about cases of
that particular topic
okay and this is basically just a quick
example data and this is how I parted it
in a text file you probably don't want
to store this in a text file usually
because it can get really large but this
is just to give you a sense of what it
looks like so a bunch of features and
this is like I think like one yeah this
is one month of data and so the way I
have it set up is like there's lines of
data for each account and each line
represents a different month right and
so this data can be very big which is
probably unsurprising because it's time
series right so not only do you have
your account dimension and your features
dimension but you have a third dimension
which is time and so you can get like
huge amounts of data we decided to store
it as a map numpy men that beret which
stores your data on disk but allows you
to access it just like it was a normal
in memory numpy array this might not
necessarily be the best solution for you
it can be really slow to access the data
once it's in this format and so I I
basically do some parallel processing
when I'm training the model where I'm as
one particular batch is getting passed
through the model I'm fetching the next
batch from the mem map race and I have
to wait for that on the next iteration
and so you have the shape of this like I
mentioned before is it's a three
dimensional matrix and so like if you're
not used to linear algebra again that
can be kind of confusing and so another
way to think about is that it's a list a
Python list where each element of the
list is a matrix and so each the first
element for example was to our first
account and
it's rows are the time steps and then
it's columns are the features okay cool
so now we're ready that now we've got
our date already we can train and test
our model and the only sort of trick I
want to draw your attention to is that
what we're currently on that works right
we're trying to predict an output at
every single time step with our model we
don't necessarily there's not it doesn't
necessarily make sense to make a
prediction every time step because the
customer might not be a risk of dropping
assets right if they don't have any
assets expiring then it doesn't make
sense to predict that some assets are
expiring right and so the way to handle
that is to basically mask your error
function so any month where they don't
have assets expiring you multiply by
zero essentially and that takes out that
part of the air and so that air doesn't
get back propagated through the model
when it's training you then build the
model and so if you guys are at the
Kara's talk yesterday using something
like Harris or lasagna is probably the
way to go it makes a lot easier you guys
can look at this later um I I use
lasagna originally because Karis wasn't
available when I first start developing
this model well I've used Cara's cents
and I actually like it better and so
that would be my personal recommendation
to you if you're just getting started
from there we're ready to train the
model nothing really crazy just beware
of overfitting good data science
practice yeah and so I I guess I also
want to emphasize again that knowing
linear algebra and understanding
functional programming will make working
with these models a lot easier so even
for people who know this stuff like
debugging Theano can be pretty gnarly
and so like if you don't know that stuff
you're gonna have a very very hard time
so that like take the time to just like
sort of learn these concepts first
before you like to really start digging
in to the deep learning stuff it'll make
your life a lot easier just yeah the
next step is just testing the model the
results you see here are just to
emphasize that we're currently all
networked perform better than either a
great booster machine or a linear model
sometimes demand metric ten to twenty
percent better these are predictions you
can see there's still a lot of noise
there's a lot of way to go but they
basically well enjoy you attempted to is
this table here and basically what this
table tells us is that if we were to try
to identify the customers who were the
most risk at risk of dropping their
assets using a naive approach where we
just look at the potential number of
assets that could be expired versus a
recurrent neural network the recurrent
neural network detected 100 more than
the naive approach and so how am i how
am i on time five minutes okay I'm a
hustle through this we also built a
model for predicting customer for
predicting customer escalations on
support cases so customer opens a case
with red hat when they have issued their
software creates this dialog etc etc we
basically did a very similar approach to
the asset model where we get a bunch of
features put those in time series and
try to predict this model is still very
experimental you can see this is the
distribution of predictions for truly
escalated versus not escalated you can
see that the escalated are being shifted
slightly to the right but there's still
a lot of overlap and the potential
impact of this is so like if we looked
at this number of cases for a given time
period and what percentage of the truly
escalated cases does the model capture
and so with the recurrent neural network
we detected 20% using that even approach
we only got 15% says the 33% increase in
our to positive rate which is good but
there's still obviously a long way to go
in terms of that model and so I want to
quickly point out this model that I'm
working on right now the the original
customer escalation model was using like
some latent semantic indexing of the
text for the cases to as the text
features I'm now working on them all
that sort of is jointly learning the
text with the other case features at
each time step and the way of student
that is it's doing like some
convolutional neural network stuff
within each time step within the
recurrent neural network and so I have
my code on github if you want to check
that out so that we also did a word
Tyvek model not gonna spend a lot of
time I will point out my batter picture
to vex model
I've learned some distributed
representations of major league baseball
players by trying to predict the output
of a given pitch so check that off your
baseball fans but what we learned on
this model these are actual examples of
analogies that we learn from our
distributive representations so you can
see that bash - shell shock + heartbleed
equals OpenSSL and if you're up-to-date
on your Linux vulnerabilities you'll
know that shell shock was a bash
vulnerability and heartbleed wasn't open
SSL vulnerability so it's pretty red
right yeah and these are just other
examples from our actual data set that
we were to learn able to learn finally
I've been experimenting with a decent
Mantic similarity model that was first
described by Microsoft Research my
implementation is also on my github and
the way this works is so if you're
familiar with typical search what they
usually do is do a tf-idf matrix and
they basically take the cosine
similarity of those vectors and if
they're really similar then those little
results are returned this approach tries
to model those latent like semantic
vectors using a convolutional neural
network again and so they learn these
convolutional they learn these latent
vectors by performing these
convolutional operations over the text
and then they take the cosine similarity
of that and basically pass it through
the softmax function that's what allows
you to train the model and that is it I
don't know if we have any time for
questions I appreciate it thank you okay
sweet
this is this is for posterity so you had
a layer in your model where you're
running an SBB on your webpage views
which are you know huge sparse matrix
but the SVD is going to be dense in
general yeah right and yet later you
have you're doing Lda because you have
count value data so why not use count
value data for the web pages yeah sweet
all the web page views is a document and
then you're capturing something it's
more like the sparsity if you guys tried
something like that
that's iteration two that's what we work
on yeah it's a very good observation he
makes a really good point so basically
rather than treat the document has like
a rep as we did with like the proportion
of views being your vector you can treat
it as counts like just like the lane
dear slate allocation model and that
like allows you to do this the lane D
really allocation modeling basically
which hopefully will lead to better
results we would expect that it would
all right let's thank our speaker one
more time